essentially yeah but something that came
up with uh bert kreischer
and christie stefano talking
on their podcast this week they were on
two bears one cave
and this really just struck me so i
really wanted to share this with you and
the hot breath the verse and um really
just kind of
discuss this topic for a few minutes
just on the relevance of balancing
family life
and life of being a comedian on the road
and seeing someone like chris d stefano
who just dropped a netflix special by
the way selling out theaters by the way
and yet this is where he is at in his
career after grinding for years and
years and years to get to this point
this
is where he is now
of everything has been for me so far is
like i've missed every single one of my
daughter's swim meets
and i'm like
[ __ ] you know like yeah i i just made
sick a lot of money and i'm like but
i've i watch i've been watching my
daughter's life on like a phone
and it's a little like wow this is crazy
it's happening
it's a little like what am i doing like
she's never gonna be six again you know
and i miss like tons of her life
what the what the price
yeah
so yeah and then that clip goes on for
like a while and then oh
as well so like it's it becomes
it my favorite part is that it's two men
showing vulnerability about a very tough
topic
that is
doesn't get talked about a lot
especially not in comedy right um
but i think
you know it's it's the reality of what
do you do for your dreams like what do
you do to
make
your you know this thing that you've
always wanted to do happen and yeah also
realizing okay this is
this is a sacrifice to get there
um
and this is what i've given up but it's
also a nice little like gut check
was this worth it like was this thing
that i've given up
worth it to make it happen to be where i
want to be today
yeah and it's it really gave me some
pause to like well what do i what is my
what does the future of my career look
like like do i want to be at a place
like where chris is right now where it's
like oh he quote made it and i already
feel like i made it but like you know
he's he's hitting that next tax bracket
of comedy now and he's like
oh my what am i doing
yeah i mean i think
i think as you get older
and as you like
are grinding it out in
the in any really any kind of
business or any kind of like pursuit
that you have
like you recognize that
all these other things are still
happening
you still got a family you still got a
wife you still got a marriage you still
got to be a dad all these things still
happen
just because you're killing it you know
at a at a show in florida for the
weekend
you're still a dad you mean like you're
still
and so i mean i think i
i've recognized i try not to miss those
moments because those moments are way
more important for me than
the glitz and glamour of comedy but have
i missed a moment where i was just like
hey uh i've missed a birthday i wasn't
happy about it for comedy
yeah i've missed a birthday for comedy
because i wasn't happy about it um for a
show um
and i wasn't yeah it was not fun
i mean i'm about to miss i'm missing my
wife's
birthday tomorrow
for to do comedy yeah
like
i also prepped i was like yo
i'm doing this like it was like months
in advance and so like yeah i don't feel
great about it but it's also
understanding from the other side like
oh i appreciate it we're gonna try to
you know
it's a day but also let's make sure that
we at least connect and have a good time
beforehand um
to make sure it doesn't feel like
completely that i'm out of the picture
so yeah i mean i think
i i don't know any comedian that hasn't
had to have made that kind of sacrifice
for this life though
yeah i'm always like
i'm i'm more mindful than ever of
that balance and also of like what is
worth doing and what isn't
and
um and when you when i am with family
it's like i'm a hundred percent there
like even just like
if i if the amount of time
isn't as much as i want it to be
but i can make that quality time i can
make the quality of the time better
which can make up for that lack of
like the amount of time can make up for
the quality of time so i'm a hundred
percent there
and
i think something we've talked about
before as married comedians is like that
transparency around
just checking in with your spouse i'm
about to be gone for four weekends in a
row is this cool like how do you feel
about this or
like this is kind of the direction my
career is headed but here's why i'm
doing certain things like keeping them
a part of your career and yeah part of
the journey yeah
exactly yeah
it's that open honest communication
because i remember there was a time when
i was doing like a lot of open mics i
was just like babe i need to get up four
to five times a week
and i was and it was affecting
everything
and then
got sat down and i was like yo uh
and she was like we'll need you to cut
this time down because you are not here
my bad
because you know at the end of the day
it's like yeah i want to be here like
and i want to do the things that i want
to do so yeah and so then we just
adjusted the schedule and be like all
right i'm gonna do two nights but on
those two nights i'm out pretty much all
night i'm trying to do two to three mics
a night for every night rather than
trying to do like five nights a week and
yeah i was very conscious and know that
i'm not
a you know i'm at seven years now i'm
not a seven year comedian that's been
going up seven nights a week you know
i'm saying like
i i know that that out those hours
haven't been put in in that way so the
hours that i have put in i'm exactly
where i need to be you mean like i can't
go out seven nights a week but i go up
two nights a week and that is where my
comedy is
and like you like we said quality of
time with family you make sure that the
quality of time you spend with your
comedy is also higher quality so if you
are doing as m if you do go out you're
doing as many shows as possible you're
making the most of those opportunities
you're preparing for your set you're
doing the best you can on your set
you're
networking you're really moving your
career forward so quality of time with
family but then also balancing that
making sure you make the most of the
time you do when you're working on your
comedy and it'll just add up to make a
bigger difference
facts
facts yeah but yeah i think it's a
constant struggle though i think it's
one of those things that it's never
going to be like an answer on i mean and
you know
women deal with this all the time comics
deal with this all the time people who
have dreams
will always be dealing with how do i
balance my dream versus
my reality of having responsibility
that's that's pretty much the definition
of life
yeah
yeah it's all about balance my friends
balance baby